hey du da gerade vor dem pc oder vor dem
handy oder vor was auch immer ich habe
dir jetzt einen neuen zieht vorzustellen
denn wir wurden mal wieder eine menge
zieht zugesendet und zwar aus dieser
sieht mir zugesagt worden von multi mix
dar
ich habe erst gedacht nun soll ich denn
jetzt vorstellen oder soll ich ihnen
lieber doch nicht vorstellen weil es ist
ein etwas eigenartiger sieht der zieht
ist nämlich a b c d e f g h i j k l m n
o p q r s t u v w xyz ich schon bisschen
gehabt beim alphabet kostenlos hier
naja egal mit 0 4 aber egal jedenfalls
des cee'd ist wirklich das alphabet
einfach runter geratet ich gehe mal eben
hier kurz rein kreativ weitere welt
optionen hier moment aber hey wieso kann
ich das gar nicht kopieren
egal tippen was ein a b c d e f g h i j
k l m n o p q r s t u v w xyz sorgt
klickt ihr einfach auf neue welt
erstellen und im dom zu dom landschaft
wird generiert keine los ok hier sind
wir nun das ist ein zeichen dafür dass
ich richtig eingegeben habe und zwar ist
das einsieht mitten im niemandsland
es ist einfach eine einsame insel aber
nicht eine einsame insel wohl einfach
einen kleinen abschnitt mit einem baum
drauf habt sondern ihr habt da ein baum
da habt ihr ein bisschen sand da habt
ihr so gras wo ihr euch vielleicht meine
farm ausmachen könnte überall sonst ist
wasser hier sind tintenfische stopp da
waren auch ingo tintenfische also vorhin
beim test waren hier auch irgendwo
tintenfische ihr habt ihr zucker prüfen
welche bücherregale nachher und teilt
hier auch clay oder so was halt die
wichtigsten sachen ok clay setzt sich
gerade wichtig aber die wichtigsten
sachen hat man man hat auch hier unten
eisen und das auch noch alle genau hier
eine höhle habe ich jetzt noch nicht
gefunden ich bin jetzt noch schon ein
bisschen durch geflogen man hat hier
eine direkte anbindung zu mehr aber ich
weiß nicht genau was das bringt
jedenfalls wenn ihr einen überlebenszeit
haben wollt oder einfach dieses lied
könnte man so leicht als adventure web
einfach online stellen einfach so die
welt sich herunterladen online stellen
das wäre so einfach weil ich würde
anfangen wird mit dem baumfällen wird
erwarten würde warten bis sich dann in
sipplingen habt wird mit einem baum
fahren bauen dann aus dem eisen
irgendwie
keine werkzeuge machen sondern ein und
dann irgendwo eine farm hin machen hier
mit diesen ganzen gras versteigern
übernehmen weil hier kommen darauf
wartet moment hier kommen wir auch in
franzis raus die er dann einfach hin
pflanzen könnt ok for perfekt gegen
programms die total.com schon kommt
schon egal jedenfalls ist das echt so
ein richtig geiler survival sid ich zeig
euch das mal ja man ist einfach halt auf
seiner insel auf sonder kleinen
beziehungsweise etwas größeren aber halt
ziemlich einsam mitten im niemandsland
einfach mal so ein bisschen anderer
zieht nicht immer so tolle landschaften
ganz ganz viele sachen die da zu sehen
sind sondern einfach mal so eine insel
wo man wirklich einfach dem bitteren
überleben ausgesetzt ist sage ich mal
und ja wie immer wenn euch das video
gefallen hat ich würde mich aber enorm
hoch freuen wenn nicht dann einen daumen
runter bitte geben und er schreibt mir
wieder zieht sich kommentare vielleicht
ist euer kommentar das nächste mal
eingeblendet und im video dabei da
hinten ist auch noch eine kleine insel
naja egal oder hinten ist eine kleine
eisfläche naja jedenfalls ihr seid ihr
erstmal bisschen auf euch allein
gestellt vielleicht ist da hinten noch
festland oder hier irgendwo aber ihr
könnt ihr hier erstmal ein bisschen
zocken sieht es einfach das alphabet
ich wünsche euch viel spaß auf dieser
map tschüss und bis zum nächsten mal